In the previous video, we started the
renovation of our German yellow van.
We want to transform it into a comfortable,
and long lasting living space.
We leveled it, and ripped it apart.
We started planning
and designing the new interior.
Dig the trench to bring electricity
and change the door.
Now, we are going to finish the work.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
So, here we are, back in the van.
Last, night we took out the roof.
Now, we have some sort of a cabriolet.
We cover it with a tarp just in case
the rain comes, to not ruin all of our work.
Now, the next step would be
to put in the roof, insulate the whole van...
And, start with the fun part, which is the details
the furniture, and finish up the space.
So, the first thing needed is to make
the frame for the interior and the roof.
We're going to start
by cutting the wooden beams.
And now, the beams of the frame are finished!
As you can see, the fiberglass is out.
So, we're going to start roofing.
First, we add some of the wall studs
on top of the van to all the rafters.
And now, we can put the rafters on.
So, this is the old driver's seat.
And, because we want to add a table
over there for working...
We want to turn the old seat 90 degrees, to face that way.
So, that's why we are trying
to take the rail up and reangle the seat.
And then, we find a lot of switches
around the cockpit.
So, this is one of the switches
that used to connect the old battery.
And, we think it is very interesting,
and we might be able to use it for the light of the van.
It's easier if you can just
move it like this, to I guess work?
Cool!
Next!
Okay, as you can see, the framing is done!
Right now, we are going to start with insulation.
We're going to use the same materials in the ruin.
It's cork.
So, yeah, let's go!
Now that the walls are insulated,
we need to get some wood to cover it.
We got a call from the local sawmill.
They just received a batch of old floor,
from a sport club of the town close by.
So, it’s this kind of wood that used to be flooring
for a basketball court, for futsal
And, it's in very good state actually!
It still has the lines, as you can see.
But, we thought this was a great opportunity for us to get!
And, to see what we can do with it, to include it
in our renovation of the yellow van.
We like this wood for several reasons.
It's reused, it's high quality, which would make it last longer.
And, otherwise, no one would use it...
On top of it, we are also going
for the offcuts of this batch.
This will definitely bring more challenge to the process,
but we like to reuse as much as we can.
And if not us, then who?
Yeah, so, we got this pile of wood from the sawmill yesterday.
You can see there’s a lot of tracks, a lot of dirt...
So, the first step we need to do to reuse
is to sand it and clean it.
We sanded one side and on the other side,
we kept the original plastic layer.
This is good for protecting the wood.
With the roof boards in place, I made a small frame
where I'm going to put the cork in.
Okay, so we're going to start isolating the roof.
We're going to use cork again!
And, after that, a metal sheet to make it waterproof.
Okay, so, we finished putting the isolation on the roof.
We made a frame around the isolation
Because, we're going to put a metal sheet over it,
and we're going to bend it over.
- Move it a tiny bit.
Perfect!
- You got it?
Yup!
- Cool!
Went well!
Okay, so, I'm using the wood that Kevin is sanding.
It's wood from an old basketball court, from around here.
Yeah, it's pretty tough to fit,
because it's already been fit...
This is the second time we are putting it together,
so the joints are broken, and they don't fit very well...
So, we have to hammer them down.
But, it's looking really nice!
And yes, reclaimed wood, and also white oak.
So, it's going to be beautiful!
Okay, so, we are making progress
on the walls and on the floor.
But, before we are starting with this wall,
we are going to frame, like a little box here.
So, we can run the wires through it.
And, then first, we are going to cover this box,
with the same oak panels
And then, start on this wall...
So, we finished what we had to do to be able,
to finish the siding.
We ran the cables through also,
because now we're going to put two sockets on this side.
Precious Plastic sockets!
So yeah, socket time!
Okay, so, we have this old switch
of the battery system that was in the van...
And, we want to use it to as the switch for the LED-lights,
that we're going to put in the van.
So, yeah, just try to fit it in, and see if it works!
We are connecting the switch,
and checking if the net works.
Or, if the switch works...
I already installed the transformer!
Kevin wants to reuse this old light,
that was in the van as a reading light.
So, yeah, I'm going to run the wire for this thing here,
and then the wires for the LED strip.
Okay!
Let’s check...
- Okay.
Yeah?
So, it wasn't as easy as we expected, was it Kevin?
- Yeah, it is!
But, it works!
So, we are happy.
Cool!
Okay, the electrics are in place.
Now, we can finish the walls.
- Is it Christmas, Jaime?
It’s Christmas, yeah...
So, most of the siding is done.
We are still missing the last pieces,
but we're waiting for the lights, because we want to put lights in it.
So, now, we are going to start making the bed,
and the little sink area.
I'm now trying to build a table here,
because we're turning this travel seat around.
And, we try to use this place as an office.
So, we need a two level table here.
The lower part will be movable.
It will slide out and slide in,
to be more flexible in this space.
So, this is now a snug office!
And then, we are going to finish
all the little stuff, like the curtains...
Other details, things with the sewing machine,
and with old fabric.
And, so, this will be the sewing station for now.
Okay, so, right now, I'm going to start cutting,
and preparing these old cedar boards.
We're going to make a little sink area,
and a wardrobe from it.
So, cutting, sanding, and then I will install it in the yellow van.
So, the sink area is almost done.
Now, we're going to try it!
So, the shelves are almost done!
And, now, we're going to go to the van, and try and fit it.
Hello Kevin!
- Hello!
Everything fits!
Now, the last part is to make a hole here,
to fit the new sink.
Okay, so, all the siding is done, finally.
So, now, we're going to start sanding everything again.
But, luckily, I have the best sander in the Kamp...
Mariona!
- Hello!
Ready to get your hands dirty?
- Yes, let’s go!
Let's start sanding!
So, everything is sanded!
We vacuumed all of the dust out,
and now we're going to start oiling.
We're going to use a thin coat of linseed oil, in the whole van.
So, yeah, let’s start oiling.
Okay, all of that is now done!
Now, I'm putting LED strip on the edge of the wall.
Which is this one, to try to mimic the effect
of having light, coming through from the roof.
Blue is red?
- Blue is black!
I am putting the solder...
- And, I'm pretty happy he's doing it...
I have fat fingers.
It works!
Okay, so, right now we are already
on the final steps of the build.
We're going to be finishing up some details,
and Kevin is still finishing curtains and everything with fabric.
I'm going to be installing the door lock,
the door knob, wood trims around it...
And, yeah, some little stuff that still has to be done.
Let’s go in!
So, this part is really transparent,
and everyone can see through.
So, for this curtain, we choose some thick fabric,
like the jeans, to make a curtain to cover.
With this white fabric, the light really goes through.
So, we want to put it at a door.
Now, I'm taking it apart really carefully...
Do you know what this is, Mariona?
- No, what is it, Jaime?
It's the last piece.
- No!
Yeah!
I'm done...
Jaime, what is this piece here?
Is it not oiled?
- This one?
It’s the funny thing about filming...
You put on a GoPro, and then you forget to oil it...
So, yeah, we have to oil it again.
But, it's just a little piece...
Not that much...
- Easy peasy?
We’re close to finishing the van.
Now, I'm putting the slats in place,
so we can put the mattress in.
So, we already finished the bed,
and the mattress has arrived.
So, we're going to put the mattress in.
That's it!
Fits good!
In the meantime, I'm doing the sheets for
the new bed, made out of old shirts.
We like to give new life to material.
So, we got this shirt from a second hand shop close by.
Ready to sew!
Around this height, or...?
With the leftover pockets, I decided to make something
next to the bed, to keep the gadgets organized.
- What's that for, Kevin?
This is for the phone to sleep in.
- Hey, cool!
I also installed a little rack to hang clothes.
Okay, so, we finished the last pieces of furniture.
So, now, the only thing that’s left is to oil them.
I could oil like this all day.
Comfy!
This van will not drive anymore.
So, I have a better place for this mirror!
The old license plate could be a nice decoration!
It's from Croatia!
So, one of the things we found on the van is this dry frog.
Which, Mattia found when he first got this van.
When I found this van, I just also encountered
this splashed frog and I kept it there ever since.
As a sort of a sign of good luck!
So, we are making a little frame for it!
Okay, the van is finished!
To give it a final touch, we put some woodchips around it.
Okay, right now, the entrance of the van is a bit high...
So, I just got this wood and I'm going
to make two steps, to make the entrance more comfy.
So, the van now is done!
A nice house on wheels!
Even though it's not going to drive anymore,
for our set up at Basekamp, it’s a perfect fit.
Now that we repaired the roof,
it can last many more years in perfect state.
We love the look of the interior!
All wood, properly insulated with natural cork,
with night lights and a lot of details.
It will be a nice place to live for a
longer period of time, even during winter.
In the next video, we will show you what happens
in Project Kamp behind the scenes,
Something you don't see in the normal updates!
If you want to see it now, you can support us on Patreon!
You can find the link in the description of the video.
Click there and see what happens.
If not, you can always subscribe,
and help us with the algorithm.
Thanks for watching and you in the next update!